[Musique]
ovo jardin se réveille l'amandier et
honfleur quelle merveille la solitude
des enfants qui qui parfois se retrouve
au coupé d'aidé aux enfants
voilà ce qui m'a inspiré c'est que moi
même j'ai pas mal trimballer les enfants
et notamment ma grande fille ma fille
est née pendant mes tournées avec son
papa au début de sa vie et par moment
voilà elle était tout le temps entre
adultes tout temps la musique classique
savait pas dire la musique d'hier c'est
notre patrimoine c'est un capital
culturel mais elle s'ancre vraiment dans
notre vie d'aujourd'hui et c'est ça
c'est en fait je zappe à dire les rendre
moderne mais les montrer dans leur
modernité bien douce nuit par les quatre
saisons de vivaldi j'ai repris l'hiver
l'été l'automne patente une un morceau
par par saison j'ai repris l'ouverture
de guillaume tell
j'ai repris la truite de schubert le
boléro de ravel que les gros gros tubes